Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and back in my
Korra Book 3 teaser breakdown I asked you
all to submit questions so I picked 10 of
them with one bonus question to answer in
a video.
I also wanted to talk a little about the Nickelodeon
upfronts that are coming March 13th, because
that might be when we get our first official
look at Book 3.
If you’re finding me for the first time
and you’re a big Korra fan or just anime
in general be sure to subscribe to get all
my stuff.
I typically do anime videos on a semi-weekly
basis and I do regular Korra videos, especially
during the season.
So first let’s talk about the upfront.
It’s just when Nickelodeon screens stuff
from all of it’s upcoming shows for advertisers
so that they buy advertising time.
During that it’s widely rumored that they’ll
screen new footage from Korra Book 3 and reveal
the official premiere date.
If you’ve seen any of my other Book 3 videos
you know I’m expecting it to premiere either
late in the spring, like as soon as April
or at the latest, the beginning of summer
in May.
They’re almost done animating Book 3, and
usually that’s the cue that the premiere
is really really close.
The first official Book 3 trailer typically
comes a month or two ahead of the premiere
too.
It’s not exact, but if they do post the
official trailer in March, you can bet we’ll
see book 3 in April or May.
So now let’s answer some questions.
Number 1 - KJ Bucane asks Do you think there
will be any MAJOR character deaths in this
upcoming season?
Yes, I think I think it’s kind of been implied
that Katara will die.
They’ve brought together the children of
Aang and I don’t think it’s just because
they look cool together.
They spent all of book 2 healing their relationship
and dealing with their issues.
The next logical step now that they’re so
unified would be to introduce a major tragedy
that they could deal with together.
And what could be more tragic for their family
than their mother dying?
To be fair though, if she does die, she did
live a very fulfilling and happy life with
Aang and look at all her children all grown
up.
Question 2 - Soraya Moolchan Since they'll
be in the fire nation at one point, I want
to know if we'll be seeing Zuko!
That person on top of the dragon this White
Lotus member is talking to has a face scar
and is about the right age.
I think it’s safe to predict he’ll play
a role.
Hopefully he will be helping team Korra.
But we really need an official trailer with
more scenes to be sure.
Question 3 - Tommy Shen says either the White
Lotus are helping Korra or they’re a corrupt
faction.
Yes, I think it’s safe to say the White
Lotus itself is still a good group.
They’re not evil, but whoever the ones Korra
was fighting with in the trailer were, they
were probably just a faction or people impersonating
White Lotus members.
Someone else in the comments, sorry I forgot
who, suggested that the villain this season
could have planted evil agents inside their
ranks.
Question 4 - Holiday Flower Girl asks So if
the Fire Nation is gonna be in book 3, is
there a possibility that we might actually
see Zuko’s daughter, the Fire Lord?
I will be so disappointed if we don’t see
her.
We still don’t even know her name.
Which is one of the things I love about authors
like George RR Martin and JRR Tolkein.
They have massive appendices at the ends of
their books with every person’s name going
back several generations.
Even if they don’t appear in the book.
To be fair to the Avatar creators, for every
one book say George RR Martin writes.
They have made almost four seasons of Korra.
They’re starting to animate book 4 right
now.
Considering all that yes, I definitely think
we’ll finally meet her.
I think the real thing to consider is, does
she take after her father, her mother who
is probably Mai or her aunt Azula.
Zuko probably wouldn’t have let her become
the new Firelord if she was crazy like Azula
though.
Question 5 - Izzy Goggin asks Is Korra going
to ride it the dragons?
If Zuko and Aang got to ride Roku’s dragon,
who was in spirit form.
Then yes I definitely think Korra will get
to ride...finger’s crossed...Zuko’s dragon.
Even if that person in the trailer isn’t
Zuko, I still think she’ll get to ride one
at some point.
There will be several fantasy characters riding
dragons this year.
Question 6 - Winged Zero 101 asks Since they're
including scenes from the Fire nation next
season, do u think that they'll tease us with
a brief appearance from Azula?
Zuko and his daughter are on high alert watch.
I’d say that Azula, who will always be linked
with Zuko like Mako and Bolin, will probably
also make a brief appearance.
It really depends on what they’re doing
in the Fire Nation.
If they only travel their briefly, then chances
are slim.
But the more the story revolves around the
Fire Nation as a geographical location.
The better the chances we’ll see her.
Because the story is supposedly mostly based
in the Earth Kingdom though, I think they’ll
spend most of their time there.
Question 7 - The Majestic Cousins asks Do
you think that will it be another Avatar series
after Korra?
Bryan Konietzko and Michael Dante DiMartino
typically take about 18 months to two years
to develop and produce a season of Korra.
They said they really want to take a break
after book 4 airs.
So if they want to do another new series and
Nickelodeon wants to pay for it, yes to the
new Avatar.
But there would be a long time between Korra
Book 4 and Book 1 of whatever the new series
was.
Assuming they don’t start writing it immediately
after book 4.
I would plan on the comic book mostly filling
in any period there’s no new Avatar.
It’s a lot easier to produce that a season
of television.
Question 8 - direncgeil (no avatar) asks What
happened to vaatu?
and is he supposed to return?
So based on Raava and Vaatu’s cycle of death
and rebirth, Vaatu will slowly grow out of
Raava over the next ten thousand years.
Asterisk.
I don’t think he’s supposed to come back
before the end of book 4, but theoretically
someone could do the same thing Jinora did
during the finale to bring him back sooner.
Remember she helped Korra extract Raava from
Vaatu before she grew powerful enough by herself.
They don’t really have gender, but she’s
voiced by a woman, so I choose to use that
pronoun.
We can talk more about the mechanics of that
in the comments.
Question 9 - gaberoid asks Will we get more
toph in book 3?
Yes, but probably mostly in Flashbacks.
Although on the show they haven’t explicitly
said Toph is dead.
The other characters exclusively refer to
her in past tense and Katara said that many
of my friends are gone.
Zuko, of course, we know is still alive.
But yes, lot’s of Beifong backstory coming,
which paves the way for lot’s of Toph with
Baby Beifong flashbacks.
So get excited for that!
Question 10 - Kaitlyn Li asks Is asami going
to be featured heavily in Book 3?
Yes, she and Korra aren’t frenemies anymore.
They’re going to be super buddies.
I’m sure Tumblr will create the most epic
of ‘ships based on their scenes.
Like I said, there will be much less teen
romance, love triangle whatnot.
Meaning it will be easier for Korra and Asami
to be friends.
Bonus Question - Vantastic asks Since the
avatar connection is broken between korra
and the past avatars, will aang still be able
to make a cameo?
Yes, but just like Toph probably only in Flashbacks.
The children of Aang are all there, so they’ll
also probably invoke a lot of Aang moments
themselves in addition to Korra.
Thanks so much everyone for submitting questions,
this was a lot of fun as always.
Hopefully there will be some better news about
Book 3 in the next two weeks.
Until then leave your suggestions for what
you want me to do my next Korra video on.
Oscars this weekend.
I was going to do some special Fantasy League
stuff but IRL work has crushed my schedule
lately.
So I’m just going to do a Winner’s reaction
slash breakdown video tomorrow night in addition
to my Walking Dead episode review.
Hannibal Episode 1 video coming soon too!
Right now click here for more Korra Book 3
awesomeness and click here to learn all about
Grant Gustin’s brand new Flash Costume.
Spoilers, it super cool.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives.